[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع اهداف
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من نيويورك هو
تحذيرات من ازمه المناخ وقول الامين
العملي الامم المتحده ان كوكب الارض وصل
الى مرحله الغليان العالمي
والى التي تستضيف القمه الثانيه بين روسيا
وافريقيا واسط ملفات مشتركه تهم الطرفين
وهذه الصور من بيروت واستمرار الجدل في ظل
اخفاق الاتفاق على تعيين حاكم جديد لمصرف
لبنان
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في حلقه جديده من تصعيد الاحتلال في
الاراضي المحتله اكثر من 2000 مستوطن
يقتحمون باحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي يتقدم المقتحمين
للمره الثالثه منذ توليه منصبه ويدعو لما
وصفه بعوده سياده اسرائيل على المسجد
والولايات المتحده تصف الخطوه
بالاستفزازيه
وسط ادانات دوليه للاطاحه بالرئيس المنتخب
رئيس الاركان في النيجيري يعلن تاييد
الانقلابيين والمجلس العسكري يدعو انصاره
الى الهدوء والامم المتحده تعلق عملياتها
الانسانيه في النيجر
على وقع تصاعد الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
ومدنها الثلاث الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني
يؤكد عوده وفد التفاوض للتشاور ويقول ان
الخلاف القائم يدور حول نقاط جوهريه وقوات
الدعم السريع تقول ان وفدها لا يزال
موجودا في جده وتؤكد تمسكها بالمسار
التفاوضي
تتهم موسكو بمحاصره اغلب الموانئ
الاوكرانيه وتقول ان جيشها غير قادر على
التصدي للضربات الروسيه على منشات تصدير
الحبوب وترجح فقد السيطره على الموانئ
كافه في غضون شهرين او ثلاثه
وفي سان بطرسبورغ بوتين يتعهد خلال قمه
روسيه افريقيه بتسليم الحبوب مجانا لست
دول افريقيه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا السياقه والاهداف بعد
اقتحام اكثر من 2000 مستوطن باحث المسجد
الاقصى المبارك بالتزامن مع احياء ما
تسميه اسرائيل ذكرى خراب الهيكل
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي ابرز
رسائل واهداف حكومه نتنياهو من تكرار
اقتحام باحات المسجد الاقصى وجاءت
الاجابات على النحو التالي
قرابه
51% رجاحه سعي حكومه نتنياهو لفرض امر
واقع على المسجد الاقصى زمنيا ومكانتيا
بينما راى ثمانيه في المئه انما يحدث هو
رساله تحد من اسرائيل لاطراف دوليه
واقليميه معنيه بوضع المسجد
اما قرابه
41% فصوتوا لصالح فرضيه مسعنه ياهو لارضاء
اليمين المتطرف وانصاره في اسرائيل
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا يتجدد بكم يوميا على المنصات
الرقميه ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
مع اعلان يوليو اكثر شهور المسجله سخونه
على الاطلاق الامم المتحده تحذر مما وصفته
بالغليان العالمي وبايدن يعتبر التغير
المناخي تهديدا وجوديا
[موسيقى]
اقتحم وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار
بن غثير باحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك صباح
اليوم على راس مجموعه من المستوطنين تجاوز
عددهم الفين مستوطن ويحذر ناشطون مقديسيون
من ان يكون الاقتحام وما شاهد وما شاهده
من اقامه طقوس تلموديه علنيه مقدمه عمليه
فرض التقسيم المكني والزمني داخل المسجد
الاقصى
وجعله امرا واقعا
مؤشرات كثيرات تشير بان ما جرى في المسجد
الاقصى كان اكبر من مجرد اقتحام اعتادت
مجموعات المستوطنين على تنفيذه فيما يعرف
اسرائيليا بذكرى خراب الهيكل فالاقتحام
الذي شارك فيه نحو الفي مستوطن يتقدمهم
وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن جفير شهد
استباحه لما يعرف بالوضع التاريخي القائم
في المسجد الاقصى الذي تقتصر بموجبه
الصلاه في المسجد على المسلمين وحدهم
فبالاضافه الى تلاوه النصوص التوراتيه ادى
المستوطنون الذي ينتمي غالبيتهم لحركات
الصهيونيه الدينيه صلوات تلموديه علنيه
وغنوا ورقصوا داخل الساحات واثناء الخروج
من المسجد كما وثقت مقاطع فيديو ادائهم
لتقص السجود الملحمي اي الارتماء ارضا في
باحات الاقصى بشكل جماعي كل ذلك جرى وسط
حمايه مشدده من قوات الاحتلال التي بدات
وكانها تطبق بدقه التقسيم الزماني الذي
يعني تخصيص اوقات محدده لدخول المسلمين
واخرى خاصه باليهود على مدار العام ففضلا
عن اخلائها المسجد الاقصى من المصلين
والمعتكفين في ساعه مبكره منعت قوات
الاحتلال لاحقا الفلسطينيين من دخول
المسجد لادائه صلاه الظهر وطلبت منهم
العوده في وقت تكون فيه قد انتهت فترتاه
الاقتحام الصباحيه
وتزامن ذلك كله مع تاكيد قاده الاقتحام ان
ما يجري يدخل في سياق معركه السياده على
الاقصى
[موسيقى]
في هذا اليوم وهذا المكان من المهم ان
نتذكر دائما اننا اخوه يمينا ويسارا
متدينين وعلمانيين كلنا شعب واحد وعندما
ينظر المخرب من نافذته فهو لا يفرق بيننا
هذا المكان هو المكان الاهم للشعب اسرائيل
واليه يجب ان نعود ونظهر سيادتنا عليه
ويرى ناشطون مقديسيون ان استخدام باب
الاسباط لخروج المستوطنين من الاقصى يدل
على ان الاحتلال يسعى لخنق المسجد
بالسيطره على الناحيه الشماليه الشرقيه
المتمثله في ذلك الباب بعد السيطره على
الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه المقابله لها
والمتمثله في باباي المغاربه والسلسله ما
يعني قطع خطوه اخرى على طريق فرض التقسيم
المكاني الرامي الاقتطاع اماكن من المسجد
الاقصى وجعلها مخصصه لليهود فقط وتمكينهم
من اداء الصلوات التلموديه يوميا
وقد عبر نائب المندوبه الامريكيه في الامم
المتحده روبرت وود عن قلق الولايات
المتحده من مستوى العنف الضفه الغربيه
مشيرا الى ان عدد الوفيات من الفلسطينيين
خلال شهور السته الاولى من العام الجاري
تجاوز اجماليه عدد الوفيات خلال العام
الماضي باكمله ودانود في كلمه له خلال
جلسه لمجلس الامن كل اعمال العنف المتطرف
مهما كانت جنسيه مرتكبيها قائلا ان
الاتجاه المتصاعد للعنف يؤكد على هشاشه
الوضع في الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
نحث جميع الاطراف على اتخاذ تدابير
استباقيه لمواجهه جميع اشكال العنف
والتحريض وضمان المسائله والعداله بصرامه
متساويه في جميع حالات العنف المتطرف
ولهذه الغايه تشعر الولايات المتحده
بالقلق من الزياره الاستفزازيه التي قام
بها وزير اسرائيلي الى الحرم الشريف جبل
الهيكلي في القدس اليوم وما صاحبها من
خطاب تحريضي لا ينبغي استخدام هذا المكان
المقدس لاغراض سياسيه وندعو جميع الاطراف
الى احترام قدسيته
هذا وقت حمام مئات المستوطنين من طاقه باب
الزاويه المؤدي الى البلده القديمه بمدينه
الخليل الجنوبيه الضفه الغربيه وقد اندلعت
مواجهات بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال ما ادى الى اصابه عدد من
الفلسطينيين بحالات اختناق بالغاز المسيل
للدموع وكانت قوات الاحتلال نشرت الياتها
العسكريه في محيط باب الزاويه واجبرت
اصحاب المحل التجاريه على اغلاقها لتامين
مسيره للمستوطنين الى ما يعرف بقبره
هيبرون لاحياء ذكرى ما يسمونه خراب الهيكل
معنى من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
مرحبا بك دكتور خليل ما الذي يحفز حكومه
اسرائيل على تجاهل
كل المواقف تحديدا الموقف الامريكي
والمواقف الغربيه من مساله اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى او حتى
العمليات العسكريه والاعتقالات
في الضفه
انا اعتقد سبب رئيس لذلك هو المتعلق بشعور
عام داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه بان اداره
بايد نضاره ضعيفه مهتزه وغير مؤثره بشكلها
واخر ذلك على مدار الشغل الماضيه من عدم
اقتراث على سبيل المثال مثل ضغوط
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بعدم اقرار تعديلات
القضائيه دون وجود نوع من الاجماع
والتوافق الاسرائيلي تم ضرب عرض الحائط
بكل ما تحدث به خلال الفتره الماضيه وتم
المضيء قدما كما راينا الماضي بقناه
التعديلات التي تمهد بشكل او اخر الى امور
كثيره جدا قد تغير بشكل كامل من بنيه نظام
الاسرائيلي من جهه وتهويد المناطق
الفلسطينيه خاصه بالضفه الغربيه من جهه
اخرى وبالتالي هناك عدم اقتراف عدم اهتمام
لانه ما تقوم باداره بيض فقط مجرد ضريج
بلا طحين في بعض علاقات كمان ليس لك دقيق
بل هناك دعم وتاييد كما راينا مثلا في دعم
عمليه اقتحام مدينه ومخيم جنين قبل اسابيع
من الان كان هناك دعم امريكي واضح جدا
وبالتالي هناك شعور عام من بينج فير وكل
من ينتمي متطرفه بان امريكا فقط تتحدث دون
ان تقوم باي فعل رغم ان هناك امكانيه
للقيام بفعل امريكا تمثل واحد لم تكن اهم
حديث لاسرائيل
يعني المساله ليست ضعف الاداره الامريكيه
بقدر ما يمكن ان نقول انه نوع من السكوت
او الرضا الضمني عما يجري واطلاق مواقف
لفظيه اكثر منها مواقف جديه في رفضها اكان
للمستوطنات او حتى لاقتحامات المسجد
الاقصى
هذا صحيح وللاسف الشديد استاذ حسن هذا
تعرض ايضا مع من تكونه امريكا فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه حل الدولتين ما نراه الان في
الواقع هو تقويض لم يكن انهاء عامل لحل
الدولتين مثلا عندما يتم اليوم اقتحام من
قبل اكثر من 2016 بينهم وزراء ومسؤولين
اسرائيليين هذا يعني تهويد بشكل او باخر
للمسجد الاقصى عندما يتم التوسع
المستوطنات نتحدث عن الموافقه قبل اسابيع
فقط عن بناء اكثر من 5000 وحده سكنيه
جديده في الضفه الغربيه عندما يتم الحديث
عن عدم يعني بشكل صريح قبل اسابيع وقال
يجب ان يتم اكتفاف اي تفكير فلسطيني دوله
فلسطينيه ولم يتم الرد على ذلك بل بالعكس
تم تعيين مسؤول امريكي فيما يتعلق واعتقد
هذا هو الهدف الرئيسي لامريكا حاليا وهو
توسيع التطبيع مع الدول العربيه لم يعد
هناك هدف اخر لاداره بايدن الا هذا الهدف
فقط وهو محاوله دمج صيف المنطقه العربيه
وبالتالي امريكا لم تقم باي فعل على
الاطلاق من اجل وقف كل ما قد ينهي حل
الدولتين عمليا على الارض فلسطينيه طيب
اذا اردنا ان نسال عن ما حصل بالتحديد
اليوم من اقتحام
مستوطن لباحات المسجد الاقصى واقامه
صلوات المديه
بالداخل ماذا يعني ذلك
انا اعتقد ذلك في سياق ثلاث امور رئيسيه
الامر الاول كما قلت قبل قليل هو ما يعتقد
انه فوز كبير الامير مضطرف في اسرائيل
عندما تم تمريره القضائيه قبل ايام رغم
الرفض الشديد سواء داخلنا الخارجيا وهذا
يعتبر نوع من الفوز المعنوي وفوز السياسي
لهذا التيار المطرف الامر الثاني متعلق
بالحجم والنوعيه والعدد بنتكلم على مشاركه
رسميه ثلاث وزراء وزير الامن القومي بن
جفير وزير النقب والجليل وكذلك وزير
الطاقه الاسرائيلي وبالتالي نوع من البعد
الرسمي في هذه المساله تعتبر امر ايضا لم
يكن مسبوقا كان في الماضي يتم اقتحام من
قسطوطين متطرفين لكن الان نحن رعايه رسميه
لهذا الموضوع الامر متعلق بما قد يبدو
بدايه
خطه
لما يطلق عليه التقسيم المكاني لسبب
التقسيم الزماني كما معروف تقسيم مكاني
بمعنى اخر على ما يبدو ما حدث اليوم عندما
خرجوا خرجوا من الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه
توسع فيما يتعلق بالسيطره المكانيه كان في
الماضي يعني هناك سيطره على الجهه الغربيه
الجانبيه الغربيه المتعلقه
بالباب المغاربه والسلسله الان نتكلم على
ايضا هيمنه على الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه
المتعلقه باب الاسباط وبالتالي هناك تحول
نوعي يعكس بشكل هذا الامر ليس امرا عفويا
نحن ازاء خطه متكامله على ما تبدو من اجل
التجويد المسجد الاقصى لمصلحه المتطرفين
اليهود في اسرائيل دكتور خليل العناني
استاذه العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنط
[موسيقى]
النيجر داخليا بين مرحبا ورافض للانقلاب
العسكري على الرئيس المنتخب محمد بازوم
بعد يوم من اعلان الحرس الرئاسي عزله وقد
شهدت نيامي اليوم مظاهره داعمه للمؤسسه
العسكريه في البلاد وداعيه لرحيل القوات
الاجنبيه من البلاد كما اعلنه رئيس اركان
القوات المسلحه تاييد الانقلابيين حقنا
للدماء حسب ما جاء في البيان خارجيا اجمعت
ردود الفعل الدوليه على استنكار ما يحدث
والدعوه الى عوده النظام الحاكم في البلاد
والافراج عن الرئيس محمد بازوم المحتجز في
القصر الرئاسي منذ الاربعاء
على واقع الانقلاب العسكري وما بعده هكذا
اظهر بعض المواطنين تاييدهم للانقلابيين
بادرام النيران في سيارات على بعد
كيلومترات من مقر الحزب النيجيري
للديمقراطيه والاشتراكيه الحاكم قبل
الاطاحه بالرئيس محمد باسوم وبشعارات
معاديه لفرنسا المستعمره السابقه بارك
متظاهرون في شوارع العاصمه الخطوه التي
اقدم عليها الحرس الرئاسي
ولكن في النيجر ايضا من رفض منذ اللحظه
الاولى عزل الرئيس المنتخب ديمقراطيا
باطلاق الرصاص الحي رد الحرس المنتشر حول
القصر الرئاسي على المحتجين وبينما يبقى
الرئيس وعائلته في قبضه الانقلابيين تستمر
الردود الفعل الداخليه والخارجيه بشان
التطورات المتسارعه في بلد يختبر خامسا
انقلاب ناجح منذ على الستين من القرن
الماضي التحق بركب الموالين للانقلاب رئيس
اركان القوات المسلحه الجنرال عبد الصديق
عيسى جاء في بيان حمل توقيعه ان القياده
العسكريه للقوات المسلحه في النيجر قررت
تاييد اعلان قوات الدفاع والامن من اجل
تجنب مواجهه داميه بين القوه المختلفه اما
الرئيس المحتجز فقد غرد عبر حسابه في
تويتر ان المكاسب التي تحققت بشق الانفس
سوف يحميها المواطنون الذين يؤمنون
بالحريه والديمقراطيه من جهته دعوه وزير
الخارجيه الذي نصب نفسه رئيسا مؤقتا
للحكومه هل سمم السودو جميع الديمقراطيين
والوطنيين لافشال ما سماها المغامره
المحفوفه بالمخاطر اجمعت اغلب المواقف
الدوليه على رفض الانقلاب العسكري والدعوه
الى الافراج فورا عن الرئيس بازو من سانت
بيترسبرج الروسيه وجه الاتحاد الافريقي
عثمان غزالي رساله للانقلابيين
انضموا الى الاتحاد الافريقي والى بيانه
لاودينا بالشده الاحداث في النيجر واطالب
بعوده حكم الدستوراج الفوري عن رئيس
جمهوريه النيجر كما شجب وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ومن نيوزيلندا محاوله الاستيلاء
على السلطه بالقوه في النيجر دعيا الى
اطلاق سراح الرئيس فورا تقريبا بنفس
العبارات علق ايضا الاتحاد الاوروبي
والامم المتحده على المشهد فيما قد تكون
اخر دوله مواليه للغرب في غرب افريقيا
النيجر هي الثالث دوله في الساحل الافريقي
يستولي فيها الانقلابيون على السلطه بعدما
بوركينا فاسو منذ عام 2020 ميامي كانها
تعود 10 سنوات الى الوراء تاريخ الانقلاب
ما قبل الاخير ما الذي ينتظر الشعب
المنقسم في النيجر بعد الان
معنى الدكتور الهيبه ولد الشيخ سيداتي
الكاتبه المتخصص في الشان الافريقيه مرحبا
بك سيد الهيبه
تاييد رئاسه اركان القوات المسلحه في
النيجر للانقلابيين هل يحسم الموقف داخليا
لصالحهم
مرحبا واهلا فعلا رغم القرار الذي صدر
اليوم من قياده الجيش بدعم الانقلاب وبدعم
الحركه التي تمت بالامس كانت توصف بانها
حركه تمرد محدود ثم التحق الجيش بها هذا
دعم معنوي قوي لكنه ايضا يخفي ان هناك
صراعا داخل المجموعه الانقلابيه وداخل
المؤسسه التي انقلبت حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يعلن عن مجلس تشكيله المجلس ولم يعلن عن
هويته ولم تعلم عن مواقفه كل الحديث يدور
حول اسماء محدوده حتى
المجاهيل الاجيال القديمه او الجيل القديم
من الجيش يحاول الدخول بقوه ويحاول ان
يكون هذا الانقلاب انقلاب مقارنه بالاضافه
الى ان قاده الحرس الرئاسي باستثناء قائده
الحالي معظمهم شباب معظمهم من الطامحين من
المجموعات التي عملت الانقلابات في
افريقيا من الصغار الضباط المتوسطين الذين
اعلنوا البارحه
البيان باسمي الانقلابيين هم مجموعه من
الضباط اغلبهم لا يقودون وحدات عسكريه
وانما هم في المرتبه الثانيه نواب قاعده
المناطق العسكريه والمجموعات العسكريه
وبالتالي ما زالت حتى الان الوضعيه ملتبسه
جدا من من يمكن ان يحسم فقط من يمكن لنفهم
اكثر من القدر على حسم الموقف داخليا يعني
اذا كانت رئاسه الاركان بمعنى الجيش اصبح
الى جانب الانقلابيين والحرس الرئاسي ايضا
اذا من يتبقى
ليعلن تاييده لهم لكي يحسم الموقف
بقي ان نعرف من هؤلاء الانقلابيون كل اعلن
دعمه للمجهول لكن لا احد حتى الان يعرفه
المجلس العسكري ليست هناك تشكيله معروفه
وليس هناك قائد معروف حتى هذه اللحظه
وبالتالي هناك فراغ وهناك صراع واجتماعات
منذ اليوم من بين القاده العسكريين لاعلان
هذه التشكيله تخفي هذه
الاجتماعات وطول الوقت والانتظار ان هناك
خلافات داخل المجموعه العسكريه لم تحسن
بعده فلم يعلن عن الرئيس ولم يعلن عن
لاعضاء المجلس العسكري الاسماء المتداولات
تقول ان هناك سالفه
قائد الجيش السابق الذي اقاله
بازون في ابريل الماضي هذا القائد قائد
مخضرم فعلا شارك في ثلاث
مجالس عسكريه في ثلاث مراحل انتقاليه
مختلفه في تاريخ البلاد وهو الان يشغل
منصب سفير في الامارات المتحده هناك قائد
الاركان الحرس الرئاسي وهو مقرب من الرئيس
السابق الذي
عينه في هذا المنصب وهناك مجموعه من
الضباط ومن قاده الوحدات اعلنوا البارحه
عن الانقلاب لا ندري حتى هذه اللحظه من
هؤلاء من قاده الانقلاب حين تعلن القياده
الفعليه لهذا الانقلاب ستتحدد هويته
سيتحدد قدرته على الصمود وقدرته على
البقاء شكرا لك من نواكشه الدكتور الهيبه
ولد الشيخ سيداتي الكاتب المتخصص في الشان
الافريقي حدثتنا من نواكشوط
نبقى في الاجواء الافريقيه حيث تتبع الدول
الاستراتيجيات مختلفه لتقويه نفوذها في
هذه القاره منها ما هو اقتصادي او عسكري
استخدام ميليشيا باغنر كان اسلوبا اتبعته
موسكو في هذه القاره الزميل محمود الكن
يستعرض بعض الامثله التي توضح كيف لعبت
دورا في بسط النفوذ الروسي ضمن الملف
الخاص عن التنافس الدولي في افريقيا
يعود نفوذ روسيا في افريقيا الى فتره
العهد السوفيتي وان لم يكن وجود السوفييت
كبيرا في افريقيا حتى حركات التحرر من
الاستعمار عند بدايه تلك الحركات لجا
الاتحاد السوفيتي الى دعمها سواء عبر
مستشارين او التدريب او توريد السلاح
لمحاربه النفوذ الغربي الاستعماري
والامبرياليه كما كان السوفييت والمعسكر
الشيوعي يصفونها في ذلك الوقت
بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي تضائل النفوذ
الى ان عادت روسيا باستراتيجيات جديده في
عهد بوتين منها اقتصادي واخرى غير تقليديه
كاستخدام ميليشيا فاغنر حيث اتهمت روسيا
بتسخير المجموعه لدعم ديكتاتوريات او قوى
معارضه في القاره
يسمح الاسلوب غير التقليدي في استخدام
الميليشيات للدول بدل الجيوش بالتنصر من
المسؤوليه المباشره في الاحداث وعدم ربطها
مباشره بالدوله ويخفف من ضغط الراي العام
الداخلي حيث لا يوضع ابناء الجيش النظامي
في مواجهات خارجيه مباشره
هذه هي خريطه للنفوذ الروسي عبر استخدام
ميليشيا زاجنر في القاره
يعتمد النفوذ على مزيج من الاليات مقسم
الى درجات حسب وثيقه سابقه نسبت لفاجنر
وسربت الى الاعلام ادرجه واحد مثلت الحد
الادنى من التعاون في حين مثلت ادرجه خمسه
الحد الاعلى في ذلك الوقت دعونا نستعرض
مثالين يختصران اشكال الدعم
في بسط النفوذ الروسي في افريقيا
في ليبيا شاركت ميليشيات في دعم خليفه
حفتر ضد حكومه الوفاق الوطني والهجومي على
طرابلس لكنها في الوقت نفسه كانت توجد قرب
حقلين مهمين للغاز في البلاد وذلك لحمايته
ويقع الحقلان ضمن نفوذ حفتر وهما الوفاء
والفارس
حيث اشارت دراسات الى ان ليبيا لم تتمكن
من الاستفاده من تصدير الغاز الى اوروبا
لتعويض نقص الغاز الروسي عند حدوث ازمه
الطاقه اثر الحرب في اوكرانيا وعزت السبب
الى وجود فاجنمر قرب الحقلين وتحكمي
المجموعه بهما او عبر حلفاء لها في الداخل
الليبي الامر الذي لعب لصالح روسيا في
ازمه الغاز الاوروبيه
في افريقيا الوسطى دخلت المجموعه بطلب من
الرئيس تواديرا لتوفير حمايه له بعد
محاوله الانقلاب ولتدريب الجيش في المقابل
وضعت يدها على موارد طبيعيه في البلاد
كمناجم يذهب هذا جزء من عمليات فاغنر في
افريقيا قبل تمردها على الكرملين لكن
التساؤل يبقى عن كيفيه عمل النفود الروسي
والياته في مرحله ما بعد فاقنر وكيف
ستتغير استراتيجيه روسيا في القاره لاحقا
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع ذوي متقطع
لاسلحه ثقيله شمالي مدينه ام درمان وذلك
وسط الشبكات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع كما شوهدت اعمده الدخان في سماء
مركز الخرطوم بتزامن مع تحليق مستمر
للطائرات الحربيه حول العاصمه واضاف
مراسلنا ان الجيش السوداني استهدف تجمعات
للدعم السريع بقصف مدفعي في منطقه بحري
شماليه الخرطوم وافادت مصادر محليه
للجزيره بان الطائرات الحربيه التابعه
للجيش قصفت عددا من مواقع قوات الدعم
السريع الجنوبيه الخرطوم وفي شرق النيل
سياسيا اكدت القوات المسلحه في السودان
رغبتها في التوصل الى اتفاق فاعل وعادل
يوقف ما سمته العدائيات ويمهد لمناقشه
قضايا ما بعد الحرب واشار بيان صادر عن
مكتب الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
ان وفد التفاوض عاد الى السودان امس
الاربعاء للتشاور مع الاستعداد لمواصله
المباحثات متى ما تم استئنافها بعد تذليل
معوقات واضاف البيان ان الخلافه على نقاط
جوهريه مثل اخلاء من وصفهم البيان
بالمتمردين لمنازل المواطنين بجميع انحاء
العاصمه واخلاء المرافق العامه ادى الى
عدم التوصل لاتفاق وقت العدائيات وعوده
وفد القوات المسلحه الى الخرطوم حسب ما
جاء في البيان
في المقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريع ان
وفدها مازال موجودا بجده وان تمسكها بهذا
المنبر هو تعبير صادق عن التزامها
بتعهداتها امام الوساطه السعوديه
الامريكيه حسب تعبيرها وفي بيان لها اتهمت
الدعم السريع من سمتهم
بالانقلابيين بعرقله اي جهود لوقف الحرب
وحل الازمه
[موسيقى]
قال الجيش الاوكراني اليوم انه غير قادر
على التصدي للضربات الروسيه على منشات
الحبوب وقالت نتاليا
متحدثه باسم القياده الجنوبيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه انه في غضون شهرين او ثلاثه لن
يكون لدى اوكرانيا على الارجح اي موانئ في
المقابل اكدت القوات الروسيه صدها هجمات
في دونتسك وزابولوجيا
من البر والبحر والجو تشتد حمله القصف
الصاروخي الروسي على مختلف مناطق اوكرانيا
فتنعكيف مزيدا من القتل المدنيين ويحل
الدمار الهائل بما تبقى لها من منشات
بيان لهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه اكد ان
القوات الروسيه اطلقت 49 صاروخا باتجاه
مواقع مختلفه حيث سقط مدنيون قتلى وجرحى
كما اتهم البيان تلك القوات بشن سبع
وثلاثين غاره واطلاق قذائفه من رجمات
الصواريخ على المناطق السكنيه خلال
الساعات الماضيه الجانب الروسي الذي ينكر
باستمرار استهداف المدنيين اعلن ان
مروحيات هجوميه نفذت عده غارات على مواقع
اللواء الميكانيكي الرابعه عشر في الجيش
الاوكراني ووحدات الدفاع الاقليميه
الاوكرانيه المنتشره في محور كوبيانسك
كما اعلنت القوات الروسيه ان مقاتلات نفذت
ضربتين جويتين على مواقع للقوات
الاوكرانيه في خاركيف تحدث القاده
العسكريون الروس ايضا عن صدق قواتهم هجمات
اوكرانيه في عده جبهات وقتل عشرات
العسكريين الاوكرانيين واسري بعضهم
منطقه اوديس الاوكرانيه على البحر الاسود
ما تزال ضمن بنك الاهداف الروسيه المحبذه
يوميا وهي قبل ساعات تعرضت لوابر جديد من
صواريخ سفن الاسطول الروسي وتقول ان
الهجمات الروسيه على اوديسا اصبحت اكثر
ضراوه بعد انهيار اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
وبحسب نائب رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني دمر
الروس سته وعشرين مرفقا من مرافق البنيه
التحتيه للموانئ كما دمروا خمس سفن مدنيه
خلال تسعه ايام
واذا كانت تكييف وموسكو تتكتمان عن
الخسائر في الميدان فالواضح ان مختلف خطوط
الاشتباك تشهد تصعيدا عسكريا ومقابل كثافه
القصف الروسي تواصل اوكرانيا هجومها
المضاد وتدفع بمزيد من القوات الى مناطق
جنوب شرق البلاد معززه باسلحه غربيه
متطوره مكنتها حتى الان من استعاده بعض
الاراضي او على الاقل الحفاظ على مواقعها
في محاور الايمان
ومارينا وبخموت في مقاطعه دونيسك وفق هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه
في الجلسه الافتتاحيه للقمه الروسيه
الافريقيه المنعقده في سان بطرسبورغ اكد
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين قدره موسكو
على تعويض الحبوب الاوكرانيه واضاف بوتين
ان روسيا مستعده لتزويد القاره الافريقيه
بالحبوب لافتا الى انها ستكون مجانيه
للدول الاكثر حاجه لها
قلت ان بلادنا قادره على تعويض الحبوب
الاوكرانيه على اسس تجاريه او كمساعدات
مجانيه لاكثر الدول حاجه بين الدول
الافريقيه ولمزيد من الوضوح يضيف انه خلال
الاشهر المقبله اي ما بين الثلاثه واربعه
اشهر سنسلم كلا من بوركينا فاسو وزيمبابوي
ومالي والصومال وافريقيا الوسطى ما بين 25
وخمسين الف طن من الحبوب مجانا ونضمن
نقلها المجانيه للمستهلكين
معنا من الدكتور ايضا اوس كبير الباحثين
في المعهد الاوكراني للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه كما ينضم الينا من موسكو
المحلل السياسي الدكتور الكسندر
جورنو سابدا معك دكتور الكسندر وكلام
الرئيس بوتين بانه مستعد لتعويض
الحبوب ولو مجانا للدول الافريقيه الاكثر
حاجه هل هذا مقدمه وتمهيد للوصول فعلا الى
مرحله منع تصدير اي حبوب من الموانئ
الاوكرانيه
مرحبا السلام عليكم وشكرا على هذا السؤال
نعم في الحقيقه كما اشرتم الرئيس بوتين لم
يقل فقط ان روسيا على استعدادا للتعويض
على هذه الدول الافريقيه ولكنه ايضا وكما
ذكرتم في التقرير ذكر عددا من الدول
الافريقيه التي عبرت روسيا عن جاهزيتها
لارسال الحبوب باتجاهها والسبب وراء قول
الرئيس بوتا نادالك وانا باستطاعته القيام
بذلك هو ان الحبوب الاوكرانيه هي خمسه
بالمئه على الاسواق على العالميه ولكن
الحبوب الروسيه على الاسواق العالميه
حصتها اكثر من 25% ولذلك يمكن روسيا ان
تعوض ليس فقط على الدول الفقيره بل ايضا
الدول الاوروبيه ويجب ان لا ننسى انه في
خلال مبادره الحبوب في البحر الاسود او
اتفاقيه الحبوب كما سميت اوكرانيا ارسلت
الى اوروبا حوالي ثلاثين مليون طن من
الحبوب واقل من مليون ذهب باتجاه دول
افريقيه اكل اقل من مليون طن ونتحدث عن 29
مليون طن واكثر
ذهبت باتجاه دول اوروبيه من مثل اسبانيا
على سبيل المثال التي هي بحاجه الى حبوب
الاوكرانيه
لانتاج اللحوم والمانيا للوقود البيولوجيه
الى اخره اتضحت الفكره
اسمح لي انتقل للدكتور ايضا اوس دكتوره
ايضا
يعني هل اصبحت الان اوكرانيا في موقع
الضعيف فعلا الى درجه انها تحذر وتستنجد
وتقول انها قد لا يكون لديها اي موانئ في
غضون شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر
مساء الخير من كيف
مساء الخير من كيف تحياتي للضيف من موسكو
ولكم وللحضور او المشاهدين الكرام بعد
القرار الروسي بعدم تمديد مبادره الحبوب
مبادره الحبوب في البحر الاسود طبعا
اوكرانيا صارت في موقع صعب للغايه لان
روسيا مباشره مباشره بقصف المخزون في
اوكرانيا ليله امس دمرت روسيا 60 الف طن
من الذره الذي كان من المفترض ان تصدر الى
الصين حيث ان الصين هي من بين اولى الدول
التي تستورد
24% من المنتجات وفقا
هذه المبادره مبادره الحبوب باضافه نعم
الى اسبانيا وتركيا ولكن يجب ان نفهم ان
الصين هي الجهه الرئيسه التي تتلقى هذه
الصادرات الاوكرانيه وهي غير ممتنه
بسببه ما حصل هناك
اشكاليه بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع
وروسيا كما سبق واستفت قصفت الموانئ
الاوكرانيه ومنذ اياما قصفت ايضا ميناء في
نهر الدانوب لمحاذاه الحدود الرومانيه
وهذا ايضا مساله اشكاليه عمليه استخدام
الموانئ الجديده
لتصدير
سابقى معك هنا سيد ايفان يعني يعني
اوكرانيا في موقف صعب فيما يتعلق
بامن موانئها فيما يتعلق
بتصدير حبوبها
وايضا هي على ما يبدو في موقف صعب ميدانيا
على اعتبار ان الوقت لا يلعب لصالحها مع
تقدم بطيء وغير
استراتيجي حتى الان في الهجوم المضاد الى
اي مدى يمكن ان تصمد اوكرانيا بهذا الشكل
والشتاء قادم
بكل تاكيد كان هناك توقعات كبيره معقوده
على الهجوم المضاد ولكن روسيا كان لديها
متسع من الوقت ليزرع الالغام ولتعزيز
الدفاعات نحن بحاجه الى بعض الوقت
لمواجهه هذه المشاكل بالاضافه الى حاجتنا
الى الصواريخ بعيده المدى والطائرات
المقاتله من حلفائنا ولكن وعلى الرغم من
ذلك نختار
التقدم ببطء ولكن بقوه وحزم اذا هذا بطيء
ولكنه ياتي بالنتائج المرجوه لان اوكرانيا
تود ان تحافظ على ارواح الجنود
الاوكرانيين وعلى جاهزيه القتاليه للقوات
الاوكرانيه طبعا الامر لم يحصل بالسرعه
التي كانت تتمناها اوكرانيا ولكن وبالرغم
ذلك اعتقد اننا نشهد تقدمات صغيره في
الميدان
من جديد اليك سيد الكسندر غورنوف ايضا في
الجانب الروسي كذلك لم يكتمل لم تكتمل
المناطق التي سبق انضمتها روسيا وبالتالي
ايضا هناك نوع من المراوحه الميدانيه
والعسكريه هل روسيا ستقبل بالوضع القائم
كما هو من دون تحقيق اي تقدم ولو انها لم
تجبر على تراجع
ان روسيا لن تقبل بالوضع الراهن كما هو
لانه من بين الاسباب الرئيسه التي دفعت
روسيا بشن هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
منذ اكثر من عام هو انه انذاك كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه تقصف مدينه دوناتسكو ومنطقه
لسنوات
لثماني سنوات وعدى ذلك الى مقتل المئات من
المدنيين وبالتالي تعين على روسيا ان
تتدخل لانقاذ السكان
ولتحريك المدفعيه الاوكرانيه بعيدا عن
بيوت هؤلاء الناس وجريمتهم الوحيده انهم
ارادوا ان ينطقوا بلغتهم الام الا وهي
اللغه الروسيه ومن ضمن اوكرانيا ارادوا ان
يعترف بهم كمنطقه ذات
ذاتيه لانهم كانوا يتحدثون الروسيه لمئات
السنوات وبالتالي روسيا سوف تستمر في
عمليتها العسكريه الخاصه حتى تحقيق
الاهداف المرجوه منها وحتى توقف اوكرانيا
عن تشكيل تهديدا لهذه المناطق شكرا جزيلا
لك من موسكو المحلل السياسي وشكرا لضيفنا
ايضا اوس كان معنا من
[موسيقى]
قالت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان استقبل في
جده مستشاره الامن القومي الامريكي جاك
سوليدان واوضحت انه تم خلال اللقاء
استعراض العلاقات الاستراتيجيه بين
البلدين وسبل تعزيزها في مختلف المجالات
كما تم استعراض مستجدات الاوضاع الاقليميه
والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشترك بدوره اقل
البيت الابيض ان سوليفان ناقش مع ولي
العهد السعودي وكبار المسؤولين القضايا
الثنائيه والاقليميه بما في ذلك المبادرات
لتعزيز رؤيه مشتركه لمزيد من السلام
ومنطقه شرق اوسط امنه ومزدهره ومستقره
واضاف ان سوري استعرض مع ولي العهد
السعودي التقدم الكبير
للبناء على فوائد الهدنه في اليمن ورحب
بالجهود الجاريه التي تقودها الامم
المتحده لانهاء الحرب واوضح ان الطرفين
اتفقا على الحفاظ على المشاورات المنتظمه
ومتابعه الامور التي تمت مناقشتها على
مدار اليوم
قالت وزاره الداخليه السوريه ان عدد ضحايا
انفجار عبوه الناسفه في منطقه السيده زينب
بريفي دمشق بلغ سته قتلى واكثر من ثلاثه
وعشرين مصابا واوضح التلفزيون السوري ان
عبوه الناسفه زرعها مجهولون في سياره اجره
انفجرت في منطقه السيده زينب
خلل من العام للامم المتحده انطونيو ان
شهر يوليو هذا العام في طريقه ليكون
الاكثر سخونه على الاطلاق في تاريخ
البشريه ودع غوتياريش قاده العلم الى
اتخاذ اجراءات فوريه للاستجابه لتغير
المناخ المتسارع
بالنسبه للعلماء الامر لا لبس فيه البشر
مسؤولون عن هذا الوضع كل هذا يتوافق تماما
مع التوقعات والتحذيرات المتكرره
والمفاجاه الوحيده هي سرعه التغيير تغير
المناخ هنا امر مرعب وهذه مجرد بدايه لقد
انتهى عصر الاحتباس الحراري وبدا عصر
الغليان العالمي الهواء لا يتنفس والحراره
لا تطاق ومستوى ارباح الوقود الاحفوري غير
مقبول يجب على القاده ان يقوموا بدورهم
ولا يمكن ان يكون هناك مزيد من التردد ولا
مزيد من الاعذار ولا مزيد من انتظار
الاخرين للتحرك اولا لانه وببساطه لم يعد
هناك المزيد من الوقت لذلك
وقال الرئيس الامريكي ان التغير المناخي
يشكل تهديدا وجوديا واعلن بايدن في مؤتمر
صحفي بواشنطن حزمه اجراءات لمواجهه موجه
الحر التي تضرب البلاد مشيرا الى انه لا
يمكن انكار خطر التغير المناخي بعد الان
نحن هنا اليوم مع عمدتي مدينتي فينيكسو
انطونيو وكبار المسؤولين في اداره للحديث
عن التهديد الوجودي لتغير المناخ وسنضع
الخطوط العريضه للخطوات التي نتخذها
لمساعده المجتمعات التي تواجه ازمه حقيقيه
ولمساعده الناس على تجاوز هذا الوقت
العصيب سنتحدث ايضا عن الخطوات التي
نتخذها لغايات الاستعداد والتخطيط
والتعافي وجعل امتنا اكثر مرونه في مواجهه
موجات الحر في المستقبل اذ اننا سنشهد
المزيد لا اعتقد انه يمكن لاي شخص انكار
تاثير تغير المناخي بعد الان
اكد رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال اللبنانيه
نجيب ميقاتي وجود مسؤوليه وطنيه ملقاه على
الجميع في حال لم يتم تعيين حاكم جديد
للمصرف المركزي الذي تنتهي ولايته اخر
الشهر الجاري ولفت ميقات في بيان بعد
اجتماعه مع نواب حاكم مصرف لبنان المركزي
الى ان حكومه ستتعاون مع البرلمان لاقرار
التشريعات الضروريه لحسن سير عمل المؤسسات
من جهه ثانيه شدد نواب حاكم مصرف لبنان
على انهم يقومون بواجباتهم ضمن الاصول
القانونيه واكدوا على تامين المتطلبات
القانونيه والتنفيذيه للحفاظ على الحد
الادنى من الاستقرار في البلاد
مع خروج رياض سلامه من حكيميه المصرف
المركزي اللبناني تطوى حقبه مثيره للجدل
من تاريخ البلاد النقدي والمصرفي وحتى
القضائي ولعل الاشد خطوره عدم تعيين خلف
له بسبب الازمه السياسيه ليضاف الى الشعور
في موقع الرئاسه شغور فان في مركز اساسي
في بنيه الدوله الماضي اللي صارت الى
علاقه بالنظام السياسي كليته وبالتالي نحن
اليوم قدام فراغ بحاكميه مصرف لبنان ماذا
يمنع انه ما نكون بكره قدام فراغ نفس
الشيء بالمؤسسه العسكريه لانه الاستحاء
المحكمه المؤسسه العسكريه
سلامي لموقعه مع وجود حكومه تصريف اعمال
محدوده صلاحيات ما يصعب التعامل مع
الانهيار المالي والاقتصادي المستمر منذ
عام 2019
وكذا سلامي الذي عين في منص به قبل نحو
ثلاثه عقود حكومات مختلفه اعتمدت سياسه
الاستدانه لتغطيه عجز الميزانيه العامه
واذا كان الجزء الاكبر من ولاياته ابتسم
بتثبيت سعر صرف الليره مقابل الدولار
فالامور فلتت من ضوابطها مع الانهيار
الاقتصادي والمالي
انهيار حملت اطراف عده الجزء الاكبر من
مسؤوليته لسلامه واتهمته بتبديل الاموال
لمنفعه شخصيه ولمصلحه جهات سياسيه ومصرفيه
ويتوقع المعنيون مخاضا صعبا في المرحله
المقبله في ظل تاخر تنفيذ خطه الانقاذ
المالي والاتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي
نحن بحاله مراوحه منذ اكثر من 3 سنوات ونص
ومش واضح المخرج من اين طالما لا اتفاق
حول برنامج الصندوق فنحن امام سنه على
الاقل مراوحه مكاننا حتى يخرج تخرج هذه
المنظومه من الانكار وتعترف بالخسائر ملف
اخر يتركز عليه الاهتمام وهو التحقيقات
القضائيه المحليه والاوروبيه التي يقطع
لها سلامي الى جانب شقيقه ومساعدته بشبهات
تبييض الاموال وتهريبها اضافه الى الاسراء
غير المشروع واختلاس الاموال العامه
والتزوير وسلامي الذي اكد براءته من
التهامي لمواجهه اليه يمتلك دون شك كنزا
من المعلومات بشان السياسات الماليه
والمصرفيه خلال العقود الماضيه جوني
طونيوس الجزيره بيروت
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في فقره المتابعه نعود الى
النيجر النيجر التي تصدرت شريط الاخبار في
الساعات الماضيه مع اعلان الجيش تاييده
للمجموعه الانقلابيه التي اطاحت برئيس
البلاد محمد بازون نقترب اكثر من النيجر
بلد شاسع يقع في غرب افريقيا تغطي الصحراء
ثلثي مساحته هو يعد احد افقر دول العالم
وهو من الدول الحديثه التي لا تمتلك ايه
منافذ بحريه او ساحليه على حدودها
تتشارك النيجر حدودا بريه مع سبع دول هي
تشاد ونيجيريا وبوركينا فاسو وبنين ومالي
وليبيا والجزائر مما يجعلها من اكثر الدول
التي تمتلك حدودا بريه مع اكبر عدد من
الدول وتعتبر نيجيريا هي الدوله التي
تمتلك معها دوله النيجر اكبر حدود بريه
يصل طولها الى ما يزيد عن 1600 كيلومتر
بينما تمتلك النيجر اصغر حدود بريه مع
بنين
بطول لا يتعدى 300 كيلومتر على غرار بلدان
اخرى تقع على الطرف الجنوبي للصحراء يقدم
التصحر مساحات شاسعه من البلاد مما يتسبب
بمواسم جفاف متتاليه طاقمه الجوع المستشرق
والنيجر جزء من مشروع السور الاخضر العظيم
الذي يرمي الى اقامه ممر من الاشجار
والشتول في القاره يمتد عبر منطقه الساحل
باكملها بطول ثمانيه الاف كيلومتر
نشير هنا الى ان نصف سكان النيجر البالغ
عددهم الاجمالي اكثر من 26 مليون نسمه
يعانون من الفقر
تمتلك النيجر احتياطات تعد الاكبر عالميا
من اليورانيوم الذي يعد مكونا اساسيا في
الصناعات النوويه وفرنسا التي تعتمد بشكل
شبهي كامل على المحطات النوويه في انتاج
الكهرباء بدات قبل عقود التنقيب عن
اليورانيوم في شمال النيجر
الى المشهد السياسي النيجر تعاني من
انعدام استقرار سياسي مزمن منذ ان لا
استقلالها عن فرنسا في عام 1960
[موسيقى]
اما اول عمليه انتقاليه ديمقراطيه للسلطه
فشاهدتها البلاد في عام 2021 عندما تولى
محمد بازوم الرئاسه بعدما تنحس لفوه طوعا
امنيا تعد النيجر معقلا لمكافحه الارهاب
في المنطقه وفرنسا نشرت في البلاد الفا
وخمسمائه جندي من قوات مكافحه الارهاب
بعدما دفعت وحداتها للخروج من مالي
وبوركينا فاسو
معنى من واشنطن سفير هيرمان جيكو هند
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الاسبق
للشؤون الافريقيه مرحبا بك سيد هيرمان
يعني بعد هذا الشرح نود ان نسال
من هي الدول الاكثر تضررا من الانقلاب
الذي حصل في النيجر ومن هو الاكثر استفاده
منه حاليا
اعتقد انه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن بلدين
لديهما مصلحه كبيره فرنسا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فرنسا لديها برنامج
نووي كبير كل كهرباء فرنسا تقريبا تاتي من
مصانع نوويه وبالتالي هي بحاجه الى
اليورانيوم من النيجر لذلك هذه نقطه مهمه
للغايه وايضا تم قطع الامداد باليورانيوم
سوف تعاني فرنسا من مشاكل جامده بالنسبه
الى الطاقه الكهربائيه بالاضافه الى ذلك
في فرنسا برنامج نووي كبير من غواصات
نوويه وسفن نوويه وطائرات نوويه ولذلك هي
بحاجه الى اليورانيوم لتلبيه هذه
الاحتياجات بالنسبه الى فرنسا اذا ان
النيجر هي دوله مرتبطه بالامن القومي
بالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الامر سيئان لديها قاعده عسكريه في النيجر
والاساسيه هي في اغدا وهي 200 كلم شمالي
العاصمه ولولايات المتحده الامريكيه الف
جندي وتقوم باستعمال
المسيرات في هذه المنطقه
لمراقبه الساحل
لمطارده الميليشيات الاسلاميه التي تهدد
امن منطقه الساحل وبالتالي هذا مهم للغايه
بالنسبه الى دول حلف شمال الاطلسي التاكد
من ان تنظيم الدوله لا ينشط في هذه
المنطقه الحساسه بين المتوسط ووسط افريقيا
طيب هل يبدو لك لو استقر الوضع
للانقلابيين حتى الان غير غير واضح
الموضوع لكن لو استقر الامر لهم هل يبدو
لك ان هذه المصالح الفرنسيه اولا سوف تقطع
او تتضرر وهل المصالح الامريكيه ايضا سوف
تتضرر ومن سيدعمهم من الخارج
لا اعتقد ان الانقلاب لديه اي صله بمصالح
فرنسا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بل هو
نتيجه لمشاكل داخليه ان الجيش فيه توتر
كبير الحكومه فيها فساد وبالتالي لا توزع
هذه هذا المردود من اليورانيوم بشكل كبير
انا لا ارى ان الجيش يود ان يضر بمصالح
فرنسا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بل على
العكس ان النيجر يستفيد من كل ما تقوم به
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفرنسا هناك
طيب موقف الولايات المتحده
هو هو موقف عام هو يرفض
السيطره بالقوه على السلطه ولكن في ظل
الوضع الذي ذكرته هل يمكن للولايات
المتحده ان تقبل
بواقع سيطره الانقلابيين على الوضع ولو
لفتره زمنيه محدده
اعتقد ان الوضع سوف يتطور في ناجر بطريقه
ايجابيه لانه عندما نشهد انقلاب في
افريقيا الاتحاد الافريقي لديه اليات من
خلالها يحاول التوسط في البلاد المختلفه
للانتقال من سيطره الجيش الى حكم ديمقراطي
والان ان الاتحاد الافريقي اطلع
بهذه المسؤوليه وهو يتوسط بين الجيش
والمدنيين في النيجر وبرايه في خلال الشهر
المقبل سوف نشهد انتقالا من حكم عسكري الى
حكم مدني لربما من خلال انتخابات
ديمقراطيه في النيجر وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تخشى الوضع
حيث ان انها متفائله بشان نتيجه النهائيه
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الاسبق
للشؤون الافريقيه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا يبدو انه علينا جميعا الاستعداد
لتحولات مناخيه استثنائيه احوال الطقس
القاسيه التي اثرت على ملايين من الناس في
شهر يوليو الجاري هي للاسف الواقع القاسي
للتغير المناخي ولمحه مسبقه عن المستقبل
هذا ما يقولها الامين العام للمنظمه
العالميه للارصاد الجويه
نتوقف عند شهر يوليو تشير بيانات مناخيه
الى ان درجات الحراره التي سجلت في يوليو
2023 قد تكون غير مسبوقه في تاريخنا منذ
الاف من السنوات
فريق من العلماء ذهب الى القول ان هذه
الدرجات قد تكون قياسيه حتى منذ نحو مئه
الف عام
ويقول العلماء ان العالم سيحتاج الى
التكيف مع الحراره والانعكاسات الاخرى
التي تسببها الانبعاثات وانه يجب خفض تلوث
الكربون بشكل كبير هذا العقد
لتجنب الاسوا في المستقبل
لاجيالنا المقبله ولكل البشريه والامل كل
الامل ان يدرك العالم حكومات وشعوب
وقطاعات صناعيه ان التحرك من اجل المناخ
ليس طرفا بل اصبح ضروره وضروره ملحه بشكل
كبير
[موسيقى]